ん
[音楽]
道
青鬼です嘘で刺し目社長で青になってみました
ん
うん
今回なんですけどもなんと青にツリーかで入手されました
ありがとうございますパソコンディンプス体にんっていうか方に前日リーガー
リリースされました今回はなんと無盡頭が定番ということで会おうに市場化も最大の
スケール使ってるみたいですぜひ皆さん遊んでみてえ
青鬼3がリリースされたということでか誰か遊覧をに整理 sta ということで私今
家の中に入るような桜にを捕獲しておりますというわけで今日は地下に行ったら
大量の青鬼がいたらドッキリを仕掛けてみようと思います青鬼という生き物は人を
見つけるとずっと追いかけますそしている
という理由な尾根を忠実に再現しターゲットを見つけたらずっと追いかけるという
システムによっておりますもうすぐターゲットがくるのでやっぱメイクを落とさなきゃ
メイクを取らなきゃっやメイクの時間帯バイ
ちょっと
配布メイク落としてきますでもあー
矢部な買おう
[音楽]
ああああああ
ます
ん
[音楽]
me
ん
あって
[音楽]
wh
ええええええ
バッハ
ううぅうう
a これ全部 on
ねー
ぜひコミュニケーションえっ
al
[笑い]
ブーブーああああああ
ani コレ
wh
her a ゆいくんじゃないよ
いけねええええ
car ん
yeah na na na na na
[拍手]
られない
car
ni
ana yeah
[音楽]
[笑い]
は
[拍手]
me
dea
teame
car
ああっあった